حسنًا ، أود أن اسمحوا لي أن أبدأ
بالقول إنه يتعين علينا الحصول على موافقة
من حكومة المملكة العربية السعودية ، فنحن لا
نتخذ هذه الخطوة باستخفاف ، لكن AMC
Entertainment هي أكبر
سلسلة دور سينما في العالم ، وقد عقدنا
اجتماعات جيدة جدًا عندما  كان في الرياض قبل بضعة
أسابيع ، نحن متفائلون تمامًا بأن
مستقبلنا مربح ومشرق وأن
المملكة العربية السعودية ، لذلك دعنا نقول نهاية
18 لمسرحنا الجديد تمامًا من الصفر ،
كيف هذا صحيح إلى أي مدى
أنت مستعد للذهاب  لاستيعاب
اللوائح التنظيمية داخل الدولة
فيما يتعلق بالأفلام التي يُسمح لك
بعرضها بشكل جيد ، تعد الأفلام من الأعمال التجارية الكبيرة
في الشرق الأوسط في الوقت الحالي وهي تلعب
في الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، على سبيل المثال في
البحرين ، يذهب العديد من المواطنين السعوديين إلى
دبي ويذهبون إلى البحرين  ومشاهدة الأفلام هناك ،
نتوقع أن
منتجًا أفلامًا مشابهًا يعرض
الشرق الأوسط سيجد طريقه إلى
المملكة العربية السعودية ، هل لديك
انطباع بأنه سيتم تجهيز استوديوهات الأفلام
للتسجيل  في الرياض ،
تم رفع الحظر المفروض على دور السينما في المملكة العربية السعودية لمدة 35 عامًا فقط هذا
الصباح ، لذا فمن المبكر جدًا بالنسبة
لنا التكهن حول كيفية
تطور صناعة السينما في
المملكة العربية السعودية بالضبط.  لقد تحدثت بالفعل
مع الاستوديوهات ، إنهم متحمسون جدًا
لافتتاح السوق السعودي
، أكثر من 30 مليون شخص
يحبون الأفلام في الوقت الحالي ، نقدر
أن هذا سيكون سوقًا بمليارات الدولارات
غير موجود اليوم في
يجب أن تكون الكرة الأرضية على قدم وساق
خلال عام 2018 ، هذه خطوة كبيرة
للمملكة العربية السعودية ، إنها خطوة كبيرة
لـ AMC إنها خطوة كبيرة لدور
السينما ونقل صناعة السينما في
الاستوديوهات ونتوقع أن نكون لاعبًا رئيسيًا
في  الصناعة السعودية